so a lot of people think i got the worst
room in the house and let me show you
why i think that is incorrect and i
actually got the best room
i am the only one that gets my own
bathroom so this is a vanity that i can
do my makeup on and then i have my own
shower and toilet area
i also get a walk-in closet so i have
all this space for all my clothes even
though i don't have that many
i also have a window seat that overlooks
the backyard and a second floor in my
room i'm gonna show you the upstairs and
it's bigger than everyone else's
and just so you guys can see this is the
room from the view of the upstairs
so the first part of my loft is right
here it's pretty plain but as you can
see i have a lot of space and i can do a
lot with that
then if i walk over this way i have a
whole studio to myself that i get to
create content in which is what i
love to do and behind the curtain
there's even more
space one other secret behind my room is
that behind this curtain
there's a tunnel